when I look at this ship it just speaks
CD to me if something suspicious about
it
not only is it a reefer with the Chinese
name indicating that it could be Chinese
a taiwanese but now that I've got a
Bolivian flag that's like a convenient
the irony of course about La Paz and the
flag of communion to Bolivia is that
it's a landlocked country and it has no
coastline I want to take a look around
because these Reapers will also have a
log of all the long liners that came up
to it and try and ship with it now
imagine if all of a sudden we can find
ancien 101 I thought there'd be no one
on board I was wrong
we may have a pilot ladder they can toss
down but it looks like right now they're
making a call it's a likely piece for
permission
whoever they were talking to does the
trick
good evening gentlemen what's the story
with a ship just what p.m. okay there
have been cases where reefers have been
used for narcotics trafficking typically
in South America are you getting paid
well for this job at least what specific
I'm hunting for the reefers log or any
other clues that could identify the
ships that came alongside imagine all
these long liners that are coming in in
this case the Indian Ocean all
rendezvous in with this vessel and
conducting massive transshipment
long lining boys
pretty eerie down here I'm waiting to
find either a dead body or about a
hundred migrants that are being smuggled
with no GA they ripped it off GA is a
general assessment basically like the
floor plan blueprint that's probably the
captains quarters in there it's almost
like he left in a complete rush
the reefer is a dead end I need to know
hoodlums name and I still need a motive
[Music]